this is the culmination of all of the
notations of you know okay and as a
result like a supercharged version of
this it's the fastest and most powerful
okay so so far we've been naming sex
like this by describing which are the
actual elements in there or we've been
trying to describe their qualities like
oh you know they're all home or they're
positive and negative and so on okay but
if we want to be specific if you want to
build a set of particular
characteristics this is the way that you
do it it still starts with these braces
and then what you do is you name okay
which set do you want to be in and then
you pick one of those sets we've just
talked about those sort of recognized
sets like rational real etc okay so for
example let's call X sorry a member of
the positive integers okay so the way I
read this is a is the set of numbers X
where X is within the positive just
there's my Universal set and then I give
you a rule okay so for instance I could
say mmm where X is I'll put it between
these two things between 0 & 7 what is
this
this is one two three four five six one
two different houses there you go
I've named the war that's right but
what's it that order doesn't matter okay
so you can see that this tells you you
will subset and this tells you the rules
that it fits
according to okay you could say you know
the reason why this is important is
because if I were to name like say if I
wanted fractions right on real numbers
in there
I can't list them out I can't say oh you
know if I want to say all the fractions
between 0 & 7
I can't list them I can't do it it would
be an infinite set right so what I would
have to do is say well maybe I want X to
be all the real numbers
I said fractures denying scope fractions
all the fractions right and then I can
say you know the fractures between more
than one right or I could say let's go
real numbers this time all the real
numbers such that and go from native one
to X ok now the great strength of these
is that now I've got I can talk about
real numbers right you can't do a Venn
diagram for real numbers because you'd
be writing all the numbers in forever
okay but if I want to do this all I
would have to do is draw something
you're super familiar this is just a
one-dimensional number I'm just going
from north to ten right
look carefully your inequalities can you
see I'm um I'm on negative 1 so that's
inclusive filled circle do I get to 10 I
never actually reached there but that's
my input okay so that's hollow and then
I color in everything in between
okay so number lines are a really
powerful tool for representing sets you
can even use them if you want to to
represent integers so if I do it this
way from 0 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 they go this
number line with this set okay so the
reason why this is so good is it allows
us to build sets without just naming
them more because in easy manageable
situations that's fine but in other
situations great